.
THE SAFETY OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
GREAT.
ISN'T THIS AWESOME?
DRIVING MIA'S WISCONSIN
CONGRESSMAN TOM TIFFANY TRYING
TO SOUND THE ALARM ON
THIS.
CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS ABOUT THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS TELLING US LAST
SEPTEMBER.
WATCH THIS.
>> I CAN ABSOLUTELY ASSURE YOU
THAT NO ONE IS COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WHO HAS
NOT BEEN THROUGH A THOROUGH
SCREENING AND BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, WHAT A
DIFFERENCE 13 MONTHS MAKE.
YOU AND I WERE ONTO THIS FROM
THE BEGINNING.
>> SHOULD BE ANY SURPRISE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THEY WERE
MISLED.
THIS IS NO DIFFERENT THAN THE
SOUTHERN BORDER WHEN SECRETARY
MAYORKAS CAME BEFORE THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND LIE TO
US AND SAID THE BORDER IS
SECURE.
A YEAR AGO PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
INFLATION IS TRANSITORY.
AND NOW A YEAR LATER WE FIND OUT
THAT THEY DO NOT LET THEM AND AS
YOU SAID, LAURA, WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS A YEAR AGO.
I WAS AT FORT McCOY HERE IN
WISCONSIN.
WE SAW THE FIRST 2,000 REFUGEES
COMING.
NONE OF THEM HAD WENT THROUGH
THE SIV PROCESS.
I ASKED ABOUT IT.
PEOPLE CAN WALK RIGHT FROM THE
BASE WITHOUT ANY AUTHORIZATION
FROM THE COMMANDING OFFICER.
WE SOUNDED THE WARNING BELL ON
THAT AND NOW FINALLY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IS TALKING ABOUT THIS AND SAYING
IT'S A THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY AND OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
>> Laura: YEAH, BASICALLY IT'S
ONE BIG OOPS EXCEPT POTENTIALLY
THE LIVES OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
ARE GOING TO BE JEOPARDIZED
BECAUSE OF THIS THIRST OR
DESPERATE DESIRE TO BRING MORE
REFUGEES INTO A COUNTRY.
CUMBERSOME AND, EARLIER THIS
YEAR YOU SHARED A LINK I BELIEVT
WAS ON YOUR TWITTER
ACCOUNT OF A REPORT OF THIS PENN
AUDIT, THIS ENTIRE VETTING
PROCESS, AND HE WROTE OF THE
BIDEN MR. RISCH AND HAS BEEN
RECKLESSLY RELEASING POTENTIAL
DANGEROUS AFGHANS INTO OUR
COMMUNITY.
THE LIARS AND THE PROPAGANDISTS
OF POLITIFACT SAY YOUR COMMENTS
WERE MOSTLY FALSE.
[LAUGHS]
THE FACT-CHECKERS ARE BASICALLY
JUST FPR ARM OF THE DEMOCRATS AT
THIS POINT.
>> YEAH, FOR SURE.
WE SENT NOTICE TO THEM TODAY AND
SAID WE HOPE YOU UPDATE YOUR
POLITIFACT BECAUSE NOW IT IS
VERY CLEAR AS YOU SAID THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE HAS
IDENTIFIED THIS AND NOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS IDENTIFIED
THIS ALSO.
I THINK A KEY POINT I'VE BEEN
SAYING THIS FROM THE VERY START
OVER A YEAR AGO, LAURA, THEY
SHOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
SIB.
THE SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA
PROCESS.
IF THEY WOULD HAVE WENT THROUGH
THE PROCESS, JUST LIKE THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION, WE
WOULD WOULDN'T HAVE THESE
QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT.
AFGHANISTAN IS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
YOU DON'T GO DOWN TO THE DMV IN
KABUL AND FIGURE OUT WHO PEOPLE
ARE.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> Laura: YEAH.